[Music]
hey everyone
happy holidays from abby's kitchen and
my home to yours
today we're going to do a fun little
vlog because when you're watching this
it's christmas eve
so i'm sure a lot of you are having you
know your own festivities your own
family time
um so hopefully you get a chance to
watch this over the holidays and just
like oh
feel all those great holiday vibes which
are just so
cozy and addictive and just like feel
good all year round
especially in 2020 when things are not
so great
[Music]
my favorite month of the year is
december this month right now because
it's my birthday thank you very much but
also we celebrate hanukkah
and christmas in my home so it is like a
full
month of fun and delicious food
and family and friends maybe not so much
family and maybe not so much friends
because of hashtag coven
but still we're doing our best here to
keep the the kind of holiday spirit
alive
so i thought we would do that um and
again focus on all my favorite f words
food family fun well you're not gonna
see my family
because you guys know i'm i'm private
about those things and i don't like to
show my my kids
but you are going to see a little bit of
fun and a lot of bit of food
so we're going to kick things off with a
fun little holiday
taste test um and i scoured the internet
for all these like
healthier takes on holiday foods or like
holiday
flavors um i thought i would give them a
try in real time
to see if they're actually worth the
hype or if you should just like
stick to your your your good old
fashioned classic holiday
treats so let's get started i'm really
hungry
and if you can hear poppy yeah that's my
life right now
so let's eat all right first
is siet i'm sorry if i can't say that if
i didn't say that correctly
it's yet grain free mini
bonus i don't know i don't know for it
folks
um these are cinnamon crisps made with
coconut sugar
holiday seasonal flavor um it's made
with avocado oil
they're paleo vegan gluten-free
apparently trigger warning i may talk
nutritionals here so just bear with me
but they've got 130 calories in a
serving
no protein one gram of fiber so not
not a whole lot going on there but let's
hope that they taste good so
they're light they're cinnamony
they're not bad
not a ton of flavor certainly like you
don't get that like saltiness that
i like sweet and salty combination but
they're okay
i give them to my kid the things i don't
like i say hey
do you want to try this um maybe maybe
he'll he'll get a kick out of them but
they're crispy so if you're really into
like a crunch
great but i would so much rather just
eat a
regular potato chip yeah these are made
with cassava flowers cassava flour
um but i don't know there's
in my opinion not much benefit to eating
chips if they don't taste really great
to you
so i'm gonna take a pass on those oh
this is a massive cookie that i found
this is called the complete package it's
lenny
and larry's the complete cookie it's got
16 grams of protein in this cookie right
here
440 calories always look at the serving
size because
the calories right here say 240
220 calories but when you look at the
serving size that's only for half of a
cookie
so the whole cookie is 440 calories and
interestingly
for the whole cookie you get you get
your 16 grams of protein
um but if you only ate half a cookie
which is the suggested serving size then
you're only going to get
half that you're only going to get 8
grams of protein but anyways
it is what it is it's a cookie so wire
is like is there moot points here folks
wow it is a large cookie so
that's like the size of my baby o's head
basically it's a nice soft cookie you're
a
monster
no i taste like i see what they're
trying to do here
like the the gingerbread is coming
through not as spicy as i'd like i like
a really good spicy gingerbread cookie
but
i just taste this weird aftertaste i
don't know if it's the
sweetener that's in it
not a fan okay well that's too bad
that's a large cookie that
i'm not gonna eat and i'm probably not
gonna give it to my kid either
this one i'm legitimately excited about
smash mallow
i love marshmallows and i actually love
all of their
theirs their marshmallows um these
marshmallows
are uh 100 calories and four so i guess
they're like 25
calories each they're gluten free i
don't think they're vegan no there's
gelatin in them so
just something just an fyi but i have to
be
totally honest unpopular opinion
i don't love peppermint things i mean i
feel like that's what you brush your
teeth with i don't know why
people want to eat that but anyways
we're gonna give this a go and i'm gonna
try to be unbiased and just like get
into the peppermint mood
um because you know the smell
smells like the holidays to me and i do
appreciate that i do appreciate a good
holiday
aroma so this is what they look like
let's see if you can see
they're like dusted in a nice peppermint
sugar
great if you like peppermint this would
freshen your breath
after a coffee so actually that's a
great idea have your coffee
pop one of these bad boys in maybe a few
melt a few chocolate chips in that cup
coffee
because that's what i've been doing
these days that's what gives mama this
extra little kick kick and one of these
afterwards
and you'll be you know fresh as a daisy
as they say i'm gonna finish that one
on to the drinks okay so next we've got
this organic
traditions holiday spice latte
limited edition
this is made with organic coconut milk
powder
organic coconut palm sugar and then like
a bunch of spices basically so
it's kind of supposed to be i think like
a vegan
take on eggnog and you basically just
blend it up with either milk or water
and sip it
so i'm gonna give it a little little
tasty taste
i did it with just water as per their
recommendations
um in terms of ratios so i thought you
know what
might as well try it with with water
because if it's good with water it's
gonna be great with milk or some kind of
non-dairy milk
and this is really hot so bear with me
not bad it's nice and it's it's got the
spicy aromas i think i would add
more to it i feel just like needs more
more flavor so maybe with the milk it
would be better especially if you
i think with oat milk that would be bomb
with oat milk
i would be in the festive spirit that's
for sure
putting a little bit of that into like
your tea or your coffee
i think would add like a really nice um
kind of is this supposed to be coffee
no but adding like a little spoonful of
this to like your
tea or your coffee to make an actual
latte i'm not sure why they didn't
suggest having it with coffee it would
totally be amazing with coffee
um it tastes kind of like a chai latte
yeah that's what we're that's what i'm
i'm feeling right now
very chai i likey okay so my last
drink is this nut pods um this is their
limited edition holiday
nog creamer and this is an almond and
coconut-based vegan creamer so it's
completely
non-dairy there's 10 calories in a
tablespoon
um and just it's basically just like a
little bit of fat nothing really else
going on it's based on coconut cream and
almonds
and then a bunch of flavors so i'm gonna
give it a quick shake
smells festive we're big we love eggnog
in this house
okay just a little bit we don't want to
go overboard
also super hot coffee so i hope i don't
burn myself
it's good i think it needs more
it needs more if i really want to get
the full effect
and that's how 10 calories turned into
like
200.
it's good it's creamy it's got just like
a hint
of that like rich eggnog like
consistency which i appreciate
tiny hint of spice not overwhelming
unlike the nutmeg
i would totally i would totally eat this
drink this
every day this is gonna be my christmas
morning if it makes it that far
i mean i am shooting this before
christmas so
the likelihood of any of these snacks
lasting until then
is slim to none and some of them are
going in the bin but some of them are
going
right into this right here all right
well
now that i'm caffeinated and motivated
let's do some holiday crafting
all right i figure we gotta do like a
little pinterest craft here and
admittedly i am
so not a craft person i know i seem like
a craft person
and my mother is a hardcore craft person
but me not so much but you did
nailed it i just don't think i have the
patience to like follow
instructions so i just want to kind of
like skirt around them and go as fast as
i can and just like get the job done or
like buy it
that also works so i'm going to attempt
to make
my kid a snow globe because i saw some
on pinterest and i was like
i feel like i can do that i'm just gonna
look at the
instructions here see what i can do
but i think the first thing okay let's
be real i'm not even gonna look at this
the instructions i'm literally
just gonna look at the photo he's gonna
go
here yes yes yes yes
all right so we just do a little glue
action on his feet
there's something so nostalgic about
having a hot glue gun
in my hand you know what
santa i'm just gonna have faith that
this is gonna turn out
it might look like there's something
come out coming out of this is rear end
see it might but
do you think my kid's gonna care no he's
gonna see santa he's gonna see christmas
trees
he is going to light up
that is what the holiday season is all
about my friends not
making things perfectly like an
instagram
mom in mom blogger oh that's kind of
cute
got these snow flurries which are making
my entire
house a mess because they're everywhere
already i haven't even opened the bag
winning already folks this is why i
don't do crafts because
parenthood is already such a mess that
do i really need more
i'm not sure yep we'll be vacuuming
after this
operation my husband is going to kill me
yay see i'm like filling it up as best
as i can i suppose
well maybe that's like too much that's
to drown santa
i'm sure if i read the instructions on
the pinterest
article i would know how much to add
but am i going to read them no mama
don't have time for that i am on a nap
schedule
and there are only so many precious
moments without a screaming child in my
arms
that's feeling festive festive
but like it's like a a solid
toronto winter oh he's
he's snowed in is that what they're
supposed to look like or am i supposed
to really go easy on this
oh dear maybe i got a little overzealous
on the fluff because i have an entire
bag of it
what am i gonna do with this folks am i
going to be making
snow globes for the entire neighborhood
no
i'm not i'm not that i'm not gonna be
that person unfortunately
okay so he is a little bit snowy but i
feel like
it's okay i'm worried that if i don't
glue this shut
my kid is going to open it up and it is
going to make
an insane mess
oh my gosh i feel inspired right now do
you remember does anyone remember
the british show aut attack
it was my favorite show growing up i'm
just having like this nostalgic moment
here
with like with this with this glue gun
in my arms
now there was this british show with
this this british craft guy and he was
he was like art attack now just slap on
some pva glue
and the whole thing will come together
beautifully
i just remember talking about pva glue
don't know what pva glue is
didn't know what pva glue was when i was
a kid obviously
but i knew i knew it it really glued
things together well
it was the you know it was the mercedes
of glue as far as i was concerned okay
folks there's a lot of there's a lot of
blood space up here but i'm going with
it because
you know it's an artistic um move
on my part so this is what we're going
with i don't think my kid's gonna care
that looks like a hot mess he's not
gonna care he's not going to know any
better
because he's still too young to compare
with his friends
on how amazingly artistic and crafty
their parents are okay how is this guys
do pinterest fail or pinterest
win i mean i think it's a win
this is a winner i'm just i just can't
wait to see how how my kid
responds to it do i wish that santa was
taller like
he was like a basketball player yes then
he would feel the space a little bit
more
santa work on that but i mean i'm pretty
happy with
how this whole thing turned out
all right folks now i feel like we need
a little snack we need some energy
because
being a hot mess martha stewart want to
be really works up an appetite
so i figure make a gingerbread house
i haven't made a gingerbread house in
quite some time probably for good reason
um again like attention to detail
not my forte um i'm also not great at
following instructions so
i'm really hoping that this that it
makes it super easy they do say
say four e z steps and usually when they
spell easy with two letters instead of
four
it's a good sign that things are going
to be you know
pretty fast and and simple for you oh
these are the instructions oh there's so
much
letter so many letters so much words so
many words i just
can't be bothered we're just gonna do
this my way
this is obviously the front of the house
i see a sidewalk
so that's a good sign
all right white is okay
oh my gosh
come on oh my gosh i'm going to be here
all day i'm actually going to be here
all freaking day making a gingerbread
house
as if i have time for this crap five
hours later
which way all the way around oh my
goodness
it's already not going so great
okay good
folks if it doesn't look like your
toddler did it you're doing it wrong
as far as i'm concerned
oh no she's
fallen i'm gonna have to hold this
ah gosh
oh no this is stressful
this is supposed to be no
oh no oh no
no gosh
oh i know you're all laughing at me
right now
but i'm gonna make this work just need
some more icing
see this is this is horrible
instructions it told me
to put it on the inside not on the edge
but obviously you need to put on the
edge
otherwise yeah that's what you do
dum dum it's coming
guys i'm gonna fix this i'm going to fix
this
now we need more frosting more frosting
i gotta have more cowbell that's
something my kid would say
more okay round two round two
okay
this is just i'm gonna be so pissed if
this is oh
this is why you read the instructions
this holds it on
it says right on it easy build roof
holder
yes yes this is why
very nice yes okay
well this reduces the stress level
significantly
oh no you just have to worry about
everything else
all right so now we we wait
guys it's gonna be okay patience is a
virtue
and one that i don't have um
but we're going to start to decorate
because
mama only has so much time before the
kiddos wake up
so let's see what we can do you know
what
just to switch things up this man is
going to get
a nice ruffle skirt we don't know how
this person identifies at all
look at all the different youtube
decorations that they have all the
little accoutrements
i was not given this many jib juice i
was not given
enough opportunities in life
to succeed at this
we're just gonna have to make the best
out of it
hope that my child still loves me by the
end of this
you're horrible folks
look at this wreath does that look like
a wreath to you no
no it doesn't i'm gonna have to take
that down
no i don't even know how i fixed this
hot mess pull it
together i'm gonna do some gumdrop
i'm just like picking up oh my god
see gumdrops bad choice
bad choice and i'll tell you why
because there's fat and gumdrops i think
that's why i think
and as a result they don't stick so good
look at this
why even put it in a gingerbread kit
when they won't even stick i'm just mad
now i'm just gonna
oh my god it's going to break a tooth
that's that wool
oh my god it's a rainbow ring
gingerbread house here
everything's falling down
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
why
[Music]
oh no i think i need to take a little
break
so i think i'm ready to accept defeat
on the uh on the gingerbread house
and we're gonna keep things a little
more simple
yeah i'm just gonna decorate this little
tree here because
i feel like at least that doesn't
require any construction
and i can succeed at that so
that's what we're gonna do yep
you know this isn't me accepting
this isn't me completely admitting to
failure it's just
reframing right reframing
based on our strengths
[Music]
i'm gonna let that dry
[Music]
i can be proud of that that
like stayed together for me that's a
winner
there we go it's me
abby abby sharp from abby's kitchen
so i guess that the big question is
how does this taste
yeah yeah yep just as i expected
tastes like it was sitting in a box
not meant to be consumed be honest
that's just gross
yeah disappointing but
a fun holiday experience nonetheless
well everyone i hope that was fun i
wanted to do this kind of quick little
holiday vlog thing because you know i
want to keep it light
and easy if you guys are watching this
on christmas eve i wanted to make sure
everyone was getting to the holiday
spirit
and i was getting the holiday spirit
because it just feels so good
and stamps watching so i wanted to make
sure that i was
on the the nice list uh this year so
um thanks guys for joining me if you
like these vlogs and if you want to see
more vlogs if you want to there's a
specific topic that you want me to
to um be uh covering in the new year
leave me a comment below we're creating
lots of great content for you guys right
now
um also don't forget to subscribe to the
channel
and give this video a thumbs up
a nice big santa thumbs up um and uh and
a big happy holidays from my family
to yours and i'll see you guys all in
2021 let's hope for a better year
[Music]
you